-Our first guest tonight
is a talented actress you know
from her work in the "Fifty
Shades of Grey" films,
"The Lost Daughter,"
and "Cha Cha Real Smooth."
She stars in "Madame Web,"
which is in theaters
and IMAX on February 14th.
Please welcome back
to the show,
our good friend
Dakota Johnson, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
It has been too long, Dakota.
-Hello.
It's been a long time.
-It's been a long time.
And I think since
you last were here,
I now dress casual,
and I feel good about it --
-I don't.
-...until someone walks out
dressed the way you're dressed.
-Yeah.
-And I feel then...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I feel like --
I feel like a full chump.
-You want to switch?
-Like we met on Tinder,
and you thought we were
going somewhere fancy,
and I took you
to Buffalo Wild Wings.
-I would wear this
-They would be very happy
if you did.
-Do you want to trade outfits?
-I would love.
Well, maybe next time you come,
you can dress way down
and I'll dress to the nines.
-Okay.
-Just to even it out.
-Fabulous.
You got to get your butt cheeks
out like me.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, maybe --
I might need you to give me
at least six months
before you're here,
just to do, like,
hardcore butt cheek work.
-Squats.
-Yeah.
-I'll just be, like,
six months of squats.
-Six months.
-Just super-jacked butt cheeks.
-Right.
-That's something for us all --
-I don't know if that's nice,
I don't...
-Well, we're going to find out.
-Do people want that?
-I don't know.
-Well...
-I think it's one
of those things
you got to see it,
and then you decide.
-Well, I have a movie
coming out in July,
so I'll come back,
and start now.
-I think -- alright.
I can maybe get it --
alright, I think I can do it.
I know a guy who's very good
at that sort of thing.
-Who?
-He -- I can't go into it,
but he is sort of
the celebrity butt cheek guy.
[ Laughter ]
He's great.
-Who's that?
-I can't tell you his name.
It's top secret.
-Is it you?
-He's me.
[ Laughter ]
I was happy to see you
a couple of weeks ago
when you came back
and you hosted "SNL."
-And I came to see you.
-You did.
You stopped by
the old dressing room.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We were talking backstage.
You love it.
-I love it so much.
-And it had been about a decade
since you'd done it.
-Well, let's not go crazy.
That's a bit --
that's a big word.
A decade in Hollywood
is like 50 years.
-Yeah, I know,
but I think it speaks
to your enduring qualities
as a person who's capable
of hosting the show
that you can do
it 10 years apart.
I think that's actually
an accomplishment.
-Thank you.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was giving Lorne
so much [bleep] trouble --
sorry -- about, um, it being
nine years since I hosted.
And finally, like, right before
the show, he was like,
"I didn't know
it was nine years."
And I was like,
"Okay. Great."
-'Cause to Lorne --
-He didn't realize.
-...nine years is like nothing.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-He's worked there
for almost five decades now.
He's like, "What? Why are you
complaining about nine?"
-Right.
-You had a very cool thing,
which is, uh, your mom,
Melanie Griffith,
your stepfather,
and Tony Mendez,
they both hosted the show,
and they came to the show
and they came
to the after-party.
Now, have they historically
been the kind of parents
who come to things like parties
that you're at as well?
-No. Why?
-I'm just wondering.
Like, I mean, again,
when I was at "SNL,"
you know, my parents
would come to the show,
they would come
to the after-party.
And it was always weird
when you were at a party
and your parents were there.
Are you used to that,
or is that rare?
-I mean, I feel
like I'm an adult now
and they -- like, we can all do
what we want to do. [ Laughs ]
-But was it weird?
-I'm not like, "Mom, look away,"
and then, like,
have a sip of alcohol.
[ Laughs ]
Go in the bathroom
and, like, take shots.
-But were they --
when you were young,
did they like being
around your friends?
-Um, Antonio
did not really care.
He, like, hid away
and watched football, soccer.
And, uh, my mom --
my house was always the house
that had, like,
the parties in it.
-Yeah, we were that house, too.
My parents liked --
I think they just liked --
they didn't like having
other people's kids around.
They just liked their kids
not leaving.
-Yeah. Yeah, my mom
was cool with it.
Like, my mom --
this is so inappropriate.
But what [bleep]
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Um, my mom,
when I was like 15,
I started smoking cigarettes,
and I --
she came out. I had this,
like, balcony on my, um --
this little balcony
on my bedroom.
And she came out and she
was like, "Are you smoking?"
And I was like, "No."
And she was like, "Well, let me
get you an ashtray, at least,"
[ Laughter ]
Because she smokes
all the time, still.
And I quit ages ago, of course.
Um, 'cause gross.
-I wonder -- yeah, does it make
it feel less rebellious
to smoke cigarettes if your
parents smoke cigarettes?
-It makes it cheaper.
-Oh, that's a --
[ Laughter ]
You were ahead of the game.
-Yeah.
-That's very --
Your dad -- I was lucky enough
to have your dad on the show,
Don Johnson.
And he was talking about
how when you told him
you were going --
you wanted to be an actor,
he cut you off.
He said financially.
You'd finished high school,
and you're like,
"I'm going to go do this."
And he took the hard line.
-Yeah.
-And very, you know,
impressive parenting
move to say that.
And then he said
pretty quickly, you were fine.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Was that a good feeling?
I would imagine it was.
-Well, I mean there was
a few years of, like,
"Oh, I can't pay rent
this month," and you know,
but I figured it out.
[ Laughter ]
-Uh, you did a really --
we were talking backstage
about this as well.
You did a really funny sketch
with the Please Don't Destroy
boys.
I think it's okay to call them
the Please Don't Destroy boys.
-Yeah.
-Right? Yeah.
-Yeah, or if you're, like,
an "SNL" insider,
which I am, you call them PDD.
-PDD.
I can't quite get to the place
of calling them PDD.
-You can.
You're on the same floor.
-Can I say PDD?
-Yeah, okay.
So, the PDD crew,
and it seemed like a very --
you were insulting each other.
You called them
the Lonelier Island.
I enjoyed that a great deal.
-Sorry. [ Laughs ] I'm sorry.
-You don't have
to apologize to me.
Um, but I would imagine you had
a very good time doing that.
You're very funny, and they must
have enjoyed it as well.
-I had a great time.
[ Laughter ]
-Was, uh, especially -- what was
the -- what did you say?
The nepo baby?
-Nepo truce.
-Yeah.
-That was a very nice moment.
-My favorite bit was
the chant after, though.
Did you hear that?
-No, I can't remember it.
But I do remember there was.
-"A foot in the door
and so much more."
-That's really good.
[ Laughter ]
-That's a really good
nepo truce.
Um, I have a ton more
to ask you.
Will you please stick around?
We'll be right back with more.
-No.
-Please.